à montréal grain des studios a accueilli
la passe et la mégaproduction moon fort
et si dans les studios de merde qui a
été filmé le prochain transformers
visiblement l'industrie du cinéma à
rouler à plein régime en 2021 au québec
c'était à peu près du jamais vu en effet
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
venu chercher presque chaque morceau
d'équipements qui était sûr lire sur les
tablettes il ya dix ans les productions
étrangères et le secteur des effets
spéciaux ont généré au total de 192
millions de dollars après le sommet de
2019 il y a eu un nouveau record en 2021
avec un total de 1 milliard quatre cent
vingt millions de dépenses directes on
les qualifie dernier historique
effectivement tous les indicateurs sont
à la hausse au niveau de la production
de services donc l'accueil dès tournages
étrangers les effets visuels et
l'animation
les deux tiers de ses revenus de
l'étranger pour fait à l'historique
provient du secteur des effets spéciaux
un des cofondateurs de grains des
studios est présentement à los angelès
pour vanter les mérites de montréal on
peut dire la cour on a démarré on avait
quelque chose qui dit marie certain
momentum donc pour juste maintenir le
momentum l'appui s'assurer que 2022
suivre 2021
qui a réellement un engouement
si lundi 2028 aura été faste il faudra
composer en 2022 avec la pénurie de la
main-d'oeuvre l'impact d'un à nérac ans
c'est sûr qu'une multiplication
d'emplois créés et
puis notre industrie comme vous savez
une plusieurs reportages sujet dont on
parlait de pénurie de main d'oeuvre mais
c'est un beau problème malgré la
concurrence de toronto et de vancouver
montréal demeure une destination de
choix pour les producteurs hollywoodiens
dans les dernières données qu'on a reçu
entre autres du palmarès des baisses
movie très ses oeuvres moviemakers
maria 54e au palmarès des villes dont
tout juste derrière atlanta toronto et
albuquerque donc c'est une excellente
nouvelle pour montréal soulignons que
les tournages le cours ont aussi
progressé pendant l'année 2020 tire en
partie grâce aux subventions accordées
en cette période de pandémie ici boucher
le puits mais radio-canada moria